foreign
[Music]
yeah
don't be broken
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
cover your eyes
because
[Music]
she'll take it for a ride
right
[Music]
foreign
hey friends hope you enjoyed that video
I shot that down on the National Mall
and I think it looks really really
beautiful uh real quickly thanks to flow
toys for sponsoring this video if you'd
like to grab a set of these pod POI with
FPC tethers like I was using in it you
can do that by heading on over to
flowtoys.com and using my special promo
code drexfactor 2022 with a 3 instead of
an e at checkout that gets you a
discount on your order and it helps out
the channel so everybody wins thanks
once again to flow toys for sponsoring
this video y'all Rock speaking of thank
yous I have thank yous to offer to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flowfests flow toys
juggling calling pyroterra light toys
spin balls and Ultra POI for helping to
make all the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I have down in the
description of this here video and
special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel That is Johnny
Howard Lane machinsky and Becca
backlunden thank you one and all for
your very very generous support this
video would not be possible without the
kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and a few out there
watching would like to support this work
that I'm doing and are not currently
supporters you can sign up to become one
over at patreon.com
drexfactor POI you can follow the link
to that that I've included down in the
description of this video or the card
that just popped up if you are watching
on YouTube there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards and even
better you'll be helping me out in my
mission so go check that out please and
thank you
if you'd like to check out more of my
flow and performance videos I will
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also if you're watching on
YouTube the algorithm thinks that you
like this top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
see as well I'm fairly certain that this
is the last video I'm going to upload
before the end of 2022 so to all of you
out there I hope you've had a wonderful
year and I look forward to seeing you in
the new one here's to 2022 and here's to
the coming of 2023. I'll see y'all then
peace